all right so ever wedding um this is the
marriage of Chi trunks and mr. pig and
holy shit it's being done by the king of
Ooo it's like god damn it-it's like
there actually is one broad so yeah but
but bubblegum is not very happy because
she sees him as a fraud and it's I don't
think they're father and daughter I'm
not sure but I think he's not even the I
was gonna say not the same color but
could be a mix no oh we were just
talking about this I won't be maybe the
mother's bubblegum and peas I know it
looks like a waffle woman yeah like
syrup or something I don't know but he
clearly has some sort of weird strange
crazy agenda like he's about to marry
them but also wants tree trunks to like
work at his establishment or something
like that and then on top of that
there's also Finn is in charge of
keeping lumpy Space Princess away from
coming to the wedding because she comes
dressed in a wedding dress and I really
didn't get why did they explain that
well okay when you go to a wedding
there's normal like normally things
you're not supposed to do and yes this
is coming from a guy like obviously you
don't come dressed as a bride to a
wedding unless you are the bride okay so
she wanted to be the center of attention
eggs okay she wanted to upstage the
bride okay man also not supposed to come
in red right no color I didn't know that
not necessarily you just have to not
upstage the bride mm-hmm yeah so her
obviously coming in a bride in a gown
and everything yeah okay so she comes
she wants to be the center of attention
uh all the apple tree trunks is
ex-husbands are all there but they're
camped out like 100 you know feet radius
or something like that and BMO is stuck
entertaining one of them and he likes
you so much that he has
to move in and she just runs into the
forest Oh for vevo yes you really want
to see the wedding uh so finally
bubblegum sees the king is a fraud and
even though he technically has the legal
paperwork to make it happen she just
throws him all in jail and tree trunks
doesn't like it so she has everybody
stand against her because she throws
them all in jail and the King
accidentally grants them the Liberty to
get married to themselves they do the
ceremony themselves Kenya bucco yeah
which now it's I'm sure people looked it
up now and I'm sure it's probably a
sight yeah and they get married the and
peoples are so moved by watching as she
tells the guards to let everybody go and
they literally let everybody go all the
prisoners all the bad people and
including Pete yeah including I want PPP
Pete damn it who's Pete try to remember
just go Pete Pete Pete Pete Pete
yes but I'm only concerned about one of
those Pete train remember well which one
is he again I'm trying to there's like a
whole episode about it right thank you
well let's see what was he look like pee
sir that's right that's right okay so
it's okay buddy he got out cuz remember
he was innocent
yeah but he was still in prison so he
got out so that I guess that's a happy I
think um don't let's just see what
happens with the other criminals and
yeah PB most likely watches them have
sex and I think PB was about to turn it
off so well if they were wearing a
cherry cream soda maid outfit then she
would probably watch longer um Oh Yoli
and we also get to see tree trunks his
mother it's just as crazy not crazier I
I liked it though it sort of raised
questions that I'm sure whatever they'll
answer later or whatever but I'm really
curious about mostly around the king of
Ooo like who the hell is this king of
Ooo guy
why is he clearly kind of nuts why or
does he have any power what's his
relationship to bubble goes like
all these questions get soused always
like the Fang you know it's just like
well where the hell's the you know the
king or queen whatever it's like and
there he is and they just kind of tease
at it we just know she really doesn't
like him and he seems nuts
um but yeah and the rest is just you
know
tree trunks being tree trunks and you
know just fun little things with care
just being characters um and it was fun
I liked it but I like tree trunks so I'm
I'm sure you hate it
see is alone a factory and all that
belongs me I'm sorry it's C and that's
the thing for me is that tree trunks
just obviously clear enough in the head
to get annoyed by her own mother that
could be a running joke bit just like
everyone's annoyed by their own mother
but something be even like you know
treat oh I guess I just I just learned
just now a tree trunk say no she's
annoying as hell did you like anything
else in the episode um i fucked so bad
for Beaman so did I I feel really bad
that BMO couldn't see the wedding I love
that he BMO is so happy spinning and
going oh he did it so cool I love this I
love that I love love and all that stuff
and then as yep so just goes long poor
BMO's just like yeah I like that we get
to see if in and Jake's kids all grown
up because normally we've only seen Jake
jr. and TV or sorry Lady Rainicorn and
Jake sorry
I was gonna say that was all those is
that what those little baby pigs were oh
my gosh who would have thought I came
enough time to get pigs no I did like
that you finally got to see all of the
kids now more grown up at all that I am
curious about the king of Ooo but I
think the king of Ooo what I got from
the king of Ooo is cult leader that's
all the king of Ooo is the king of Ooo
is a cult leader why else would he sit
there and say oh yes you can totally get
married but first you have to stay here
at mic
found my compound yes for so long doing
so many choice yet eeeh like if he was
the king of who why would he run away if
he had any Apple did he get thrown in
prison and yeah that's that's kind of my
thing
now is could he be the king of Ooo
possibly again we go flashback to
bubblegum creating them Candy Kingdom
you don't see the king of who or
anything like that around at all so even
by that term alone PB would have more
authority than the king of whoever would
well that's why I'm wondering because a
lot of things particularly around her
didn't it almost didn't seem like they
were set up at the beginning and then as
the world came more into focus and it
got more of a reality and the solid you
know sort of existence all these things
about her they suddenly had to change in
the head to make more solid and I think
a lot of things with her cuz again I
mean just like the whole thing with like
the princesses and stuff you almost
never see I think there's like may been
three kings or queens in this you know I
mean you barely see it they're almost
always there's almost a but there's a
bajillion princesses maybe a couple
princes and I think it's just one of
those things where it's like you know I
also have the idea that like after the
apocalypse you know it happened like
they just sort of got things from
whatever's left and there's just so much
princess media they just service like
that's what that's the ultimate you know
ruling is being a princess and that's
why there's so many of them because like
I said you almost never see the king or
queen
um so but whatever it is it's a satire
it's like a million princesses it's a
big fan and stuff and but now it's like
now they sorta have to justify it like
well wait where I'm sure they've got
that question all the time like where is
the king or queen or whatever and this
is their way working around it but like
now is was it a loophole that he's the
king are they actually related or it's
like I really am you know really care
because so we look at any cult leader a
cult leader kind of comes out of nowhere
it's a bunch of people to follow the
person and he basically says I am the
center of the universe I am the ruler of
everything therefore the king of Ooo
comes in and says oh yeah well don't
listen to the government don't listen to
this I know what's going on I Oh
I'm the king of Ooo I know what's going
I mean think about it
everyone that's been a cult leader they
are the king
somehow them had to be like some like I
said some sort of loophole or paperwork
it's on cuz she was even trying to prove
it with the paperwork but it still but
then he had the updated paper and she's
like oh you're going to prison anyway
and that's just to perform marriages no
no no but still loves him as the King
king of Ooo to do it so there's still
but again she could throw him in prison
get he had to chew his way yeah so it's
like I'm really curious I'm like so
freaking curious about this then again
here in the states I could go and rename
my name to king of earth and that's kind
of true so therefore I could get
anything signed saying oh yeah look to
see I'm king of Earth that basket maybe
yeah maybe that's a maybe there is no
connection maybe that's like he legally
changed his name and then joined like
some sort of religion that like you can
become a mist or whatever like online
and not have to do anything or something
Shelby yeah I mean yeah no that's I'm
sad I'm with people's on this one that
did I just really like your that that
would be so funny if he just legally
changes everyone would really thank you
it's the key or at least some people
would you know was abiotic like tree
trunks
yeah like most of the people what oh
she's an idiot
I love tree trunk but she's an idiot um
you know that yeah that some people
would believe him but if they still
clearly follow bubble gamma she's still
obviously in control of everything
yet his blimp has like a million beer
cans all over the place and stuff so
he's clearly not running anything or
doing or at least not well or not very
respectively
and I guess that's kind of my thing and
for me it's almost you can drag it back
to a religion thing where it doesn't
matter who's running the government
God has final say it doesn't matter how
much good PB has ever done oh she
doesn't have the authority to marry me
only the king does it's almost going you
created this everything here and all
these people but that's not good enough
we need to go higher than you and I mean
PB gets upset of course and it's like
well you know I just I don't know I felt
tree trunks is just kind of being a
jackass well yeah by she's but she's
stupid I mean it's I don't know it's
you're either gonna like or you're not
and it's like if if you like her you'll
excuse the really stupid things because
you think it's part of the charm if you
don't like her you're gonna hate you
hold this stupid thing how could you
find them annoying so it's just plus by
the way I'd like to also state this when
she goes out there and she says we won't
stand for this blah blah blah blah blah
blah and then they all get tossed in
jail I like to state no one else said
anything if you noticed everyone's just
kind of stood there for like those few
seconds like okay yeah they looked upset
or annoyed but no one said yes we
completely agree with tree-trunk I don't
think they knew what to do in that
situation is such a confusing situation
cuz on the one hand it looks like the
law technically is on the kingside and
you know if she's still arresting them
and it's like okay that's kind of not
fair so well okay I guess we're with
tree trunks and this but that it's like
they didn't know what they were giving
himself into like that so I think it
just makes him I love what you think we
will not be thrown by your tyranny any
luck I love what she tried to make these
big epic speeches but she's just you
know so slow and all about doing and
blown the factory blog the factory
it cracks me up
um but no I will say this as much as I
do like tree trunks and and I did like
this episode I think my favorite image
is thid be dragged along the park with
his face down try hold it's like you can
almost gave up he's like you know what
I'm just gonna get dragged actually I
want to say I liked it
cinnamon buns back for this one I loved
the first joke where she says you know
what he did you take the drinks around
for us
Oh for us and then like he's that I
thought you said it was something that
totally did sound like for it I thought
you said go to the zoo and back yeah
that was a really good joke I liked that
I thought that was funny and then I like
where he's shaking up the bottle and
they're completely building it up to be
this huge thing or something it's like
oh yeah I thought it was gonna like hit
the blimp or something like that but ya
know just haha
I like that like this is one of the
appearances of Cinnabon cinnamon bun
where I'm like Oh Gavin fine with this
yeah no I thought both of those are
pretty funny and as I'd like to say two
tongues is a whore everything you say
about her I'm gonna agree I just like
likes whore elephants how do you not
like a whore elephant is funny who is
old at sea battle it's fucking hilarious
that's constantly tonguing a pig well
that's one thing we forgot the pig who's
sitting there going oh yeah just so
Isobel then eats it yeah
this meets it right before the big kiss
and then don't forget tree trunks is mom
yeah I said that the know about la
getting it on with tree trunks is ex oh
yeah that's I just love that tree trunks
has three ex-husbands to that that just
cracks and you can say that's awful and
I'm like yes I I just think it's really
fun um
so I liked it I am but I will say I'm
much more curious about what's going on
with the king of Ooo and and bubblegum
and what was just just what his story is
and how how and what his authority is so
yeah I think that's all I got
tree trunks is a stupid whore it's the
funniest thing ever
this is okay not ever but it's pretty
damn funny teach throne my friend heaps
their own I have my tree trunks button
right now I'd wear it I had that
recently thanks yeah
no I I do it cuz I I care for you know I
just lost it
what an ass but I lost it because I care
for you I don't buy that at all not you
right yeah no are we done now can I kick
you out of my house now we're gonna
watch the next episode blade of grass
you're really gonna throw me out in the
store uh yeah hello remember there's a
murder going on I don't care oh no it's
a little bit of rain you'll be fine
Jory can I borrow your creams oh good
night I look good in it okay no we're
using I look like an elephant whore
where you say you would like mmm now if
I get to it first
Oh God well actually hmm right Jory what
do you think I'm working a baby yeah